why don't I play a game with the
audience here tonight doesn't that sound
like it's what people want so here's
what I thought I do
I had this fun idea I thought I'd come
up there in the crowd and have some of
you share three interesting facts about
yourself it's a new game we're calling
three about me see we're having fun
already right
is uh it's Tim Carol here Tim Carol oh
hey how you doing Jim good to see good
to be here all right hates him okay this
is cool here's how we play
just tell me three interesting facts
about yourself so we can get to know you
a little better how about that okay well
uh I'm really not that interesting but
okay three things about me I'm allergic
to potatoes allergic to potatoes well
that's interesting
that'd be a problem for me because I
like my potatoes as you can tell yeah I
I didn't learn to ride a bike until I
was 33 years old whoa that's pretty old
that's pretty interesting tell us sir is
there a third fact you want us to do
let's see oh yeah I belong to a sex cult
sorry what was that
right I should explain I'm not allergic
to sweet potatoes and yams just regular
potatoes thank you
okay we're just getting started we're
gonna move on it's Eric
Karen come on here carica Oh Karen hey
Karen hand everybody all right Karen
let's play three about me tell us three
interesting facts about yourself okay um
well I'm ambidextrous um I have an
identical twin sister
oh my god you're a twin that's really
interesting are you guys close oh well
yeah I see her all the time we're in the
same sex cult okay moving on you have a
seat have a seat let's talk to this
young man right here how about you I
belong to a sec skull okay all right sir
sex gold for God's sake Oh what's house
and I'm also uh allergic to potatoes no
okay this isn't okay I'm sorry is there
anyone else anyone else anyone that has
I've got something I'd love to share
yeah no we're not going to you okay
definitely not you not tonight
to someone please for God's sake have a
fun fact that isn't weird or creepy like
a hidden talent or a tattoo or oh hey
hey setup Wow hi how are you okay great
tell us about your tattoo I actually
have two of them I got this one when I
turn 21
oh yeah yank sign that's cool yeah and I
got this one last week when I joined a
sex
alright okay let's cut to the chase
raise your hand if you're in a sex cult
just raise your hand if you're out for
God's sake
oh this is just absurd okay great
that's fit Oh for god sake really
everybody here
try and play a game anyone's in a sex
cult okay well guess what guess what I
guess if you can't beat them join them
ladies and gentlemen sign me up for the
sex cult sad news today a local sex cult
has decided to disband immediately after
a late night TV host Conan O'Brien
threatened to join well yes it's a sex
cult but we do have standards and when
Conan Joyner was just humiliated not the
good kind of humiliation
how am I supposed to tell my friends
that I'm in the same sex cult as Conan
O'Brien time to move on to bigger and
better things I've got an interview this
week at Ann Taylor Loft I only wanted
this one thing
thanks Conan truly a waste of a
perfectly good sex cult
we were it back on requires is here
[Applause]
you